[Música]
Hola con nuestro segundo invitado del
día y es que vamos a hablar del
comentario del presidente de la FIFA
jani infantino que dijo que la
organización podría no vender los
derechos de transmisión en televisión
del mundial femenino de fútbol que se
disputa en julio en Australia y Nueva
Zelanda esto después de denunciar que
recibió ofertas de los servicios de
televisión de entre 1 y 10 millones de
dólares contra los 100 o 200 que se
aceptaron para transmitir los partidos
masculinos en el mundial de Qatar 2022
una discusión que evidencia la
desprotección y la discriminación de las
atletas femeninas y esto no solo en el
fútbol sobre esto vamos a conversar
ahora con Camila García ella es
vicepresidenta del sindicato de
futbolistas
Camila Buenos días para usted le empiezo
preguntando Cuál es la posición del
sindicato respecto a esta situación
Hola un gusto estar acá gracias por la
invitación Bueno la verdad que
a FIFA Por supuesto que le interesa
incrementar el valor de los derechos de
televisión del fútbol femenino pero
también quisiera poner en contexto este
momento Esta es la primera vez que los
derechos de televisión se venden de
manera separada del masculino
previamente para un poco introducir esto
a los televidentes previamente este
mundial los derechos de televisión se
vendían como paquete juntos con el
masculino Entonces esto como
organización Nosotros siempre hemos
pedido que se separe un poco para
avanzar en la valorización propia del
fútbol femenino ya que cada vez que
había una fuerte inversión en el Torneo
ha habido una excelente respuesta por
parte de los espectadores y hoy en día
los sectores del mundial femenino son
cerca del cincuenta sesenta por ciento
masculino y esto es muy positivo ya que
sabemos históricamente el fútbol
femenino y el mundial no tiene la misma
cantidad de años de existencia empezó en
los noventa Así que entiendo la la
preocupación de Fi
Pero por supuesto que queremos avanzar
no solo en en avanzar en los derechos de
televisión sino que haya igualdad en
Premios y en condiciones claro Camila Te
saluda Luis Méndez desde el estudio acá
en Bogotá mencionabas un poco
estadísticas en cuanto a visualización
tanto de fútbol femenino como en
masculino si nos situamos en 2019 fueron
alrededor de 1.120 millones de personas
que vieron esa copa del mundo que se
celebró en Francia en aquel entonces
considera que es un retroceso que hoy en
día no se esté proyectando más los
derechos televisivos cuando quedó
demostrado que ese argumento de la poca
visualización está quedando de lado
Sí yo creo que todavía hay mucho mito
alrededor de de cómo responde
el las y los espectadores respecto al
deporte femenino y general vemos que
esto no es un tema que solo afecta al
fútbol sino que también otros deportes
pero quisiera también poner en contexto
que el año pasado a través de filtro 150
jugadores de la mayoría de las
elecciones que van a participar en este
mundial firmaron una carta exigiendo
igualdad los premios igualdad las
condiciones que se ofrecen para llegar
al mundial a raíz de esto FIFA anunció
que avanzarían esta dirección elevando
los premios significativamente y
llegando a la equidad en el próximo
ciclo algo que es inédito y algo muy
positivo para el deporte en general y la
equidad de género pero estamos a la
espera de que se ratifique ese acuerdo y
Esperamos que por cierto esta nueva
negociaciones sobre los derechos de
televisión Ojalá no sea un obstáculo
para alcanzar este objetivo y le
pregunto precisamente como usted dice no
los derechos del fútbol no son el único
ámbito donde hay discriminación entre
deporte masculino y femenino y en
infantino tampoco es un abanderado de
los Derechos Humanos ni particularmente
de las mujeres le preguntó considera que
esta posición responde Más bien a una
defensa de las jugadoras o más bien un
interés comercial de la FIFA
o sea Es evidente que hay un interés
comercial pero a la vez También hay un
compromiso
importante en los últimos años de hacer
avanzar el fútbol femenino donde debería
estar sabemos todavía que
lamentablemente el fútbol femenino de
avanzando pero de manera más rápida en
algunos países y muchísimo más lento en
otros entonces hay que buscar formas de
asignar mayores recursos a esos países
que todavía no necesita al final lo más
importante ofrecerle a las jugadoras las
mejores condiciones para dar un un
espectáculo que siga siendo crecer esta
industria y mayor visibilidad posible en
este megavento Por supuesto que no
queremos que ningún país se quede fuera
y creamos firmemente que tenemos que
partir por ellas por las jugadoras en
darles todas las herramientas que
necesitan para llegar al al máximo nivel
dado que da nuestras investigaciones y
nuestros miembros nos dicen que en
distintos continentes aún muchas
jugadoras que llegan al mundial
particularmente del sur global los
países que seguramente están escuchando
Este programa no llegan como
profesionales al un evento del fútbol y
esto es preocupante y queremos que por
supuesto este acuerdo y las
negociaciones que se están llevando a
cabo los derechos de televisión y otro
ven como resultado que se le den mejores
condiciones y Por ende mejore la calidad
del torneo y su atractivo Camila
quisiera consultarte Cómo han tomado las
jugadoras esta posición de la FIFA
Respecto a los derechos televisivos y
tomando en consideración lo que
mencionaba de la disparidad que existe
en cuanto al crecimiento del fútbol
femenino en distintas partes del mundo
que está haciendo el sindicato para
lograr esa igualdad en cuanto a la
profesionalización de las jugadoras en
los distintos torneos donde participan
sí como te decía
muchas jugadoras todavía no son
profesionales Entonces tenemos países de
Europa Estados Unidos
Australia una Senda que llegan al
mundial y claro ya llevan todo un año
jugando de manera profesional tiene una
carrera que es bastante sostenible pero
por ejemplo países de África o
Sudamérica que tenemos muy fuerte esta
cultura futbolística Lamentablemente Esa
no es la realidad Entonces desde filtro
estamos impulsando que hayan mejores
torneos que haya mayor continuidad para
las elecciones que están participando
en los distintos ciclos que que llevan
al mundial Porque por ejemplo en
Sudamérica tenemos la Copa América pero
aquellos países que no clasifican a la
copa digamos al cupo mundialista quedan
fuera digamos de participar en otras
competencias y el incentivo a la
federaciones no mantenerlas activas
Entonces estamos pidiendo mayores
torneos mejores torneos que hayan
mejores condiciones y como te decía
nuevamente el hecho de que
cincuenta jugadoras hayan firmado una
carta imagínate distintos países
distintas culturas hayan empujado a que
haya igualdad los premios es increíble y
Esperamos que eso se ratifique Camila
Muchas gracias por haber estado con
nosotros aquí en RAM 34 seguro iremos
conversando a medida que se acerque este
mundial femenino Muchas gracias gracias
a usted Luis Muchas gracias por
acompañarnos Ahora nos vemos con la
segunda Crónica de deportes Así será
Rosa y a ustedes gracias por su atención
Pero sigan conectados
[Música]